[applause]
>> Kristin: Hi Everybody, Hi!
>> Lee Stimmel: Ah this is great.
Thank you for coming.
>> Kristin: Wow.
This is so nice.
I didn't know it would be that, this many
people.
>> Lee Stimmel: Yeah, Well we have been sitting
here anxiously waiting.
We have been listening to some of your music.
[ laughs ]
>> Kristin: Oh you have?
>> Lee: A couple of well videos earlier, but
yes we have been primed and prepped.
>> Kristin: Oh my gosh.
Thank you!
>> Lee: So I understand that you are promoting
a new record, is that right?
Released yesterday.
>> Kristin: Yeah.
It came out yesterday; it's called Some Lessons
Learned.
And it's about, ah, gosh so..
>> Lee: And I was going to ask you what's
one of the lessons you have learned?
[ laughs ]
>> Kristin: I mean really, how long do we
have?
[ laughs ]
>> Lee: I don't know, but aside from the album
what would you think?
>> Kristin: I mean, to me, I mean you guys
are all going to understand this thing is,
Don't sweat the small stuff.
I guess you guys have to sweat the small stuff
[ laughter ] so that I don't have to.
Um, but that is a big lesson, you know.
You can only do and worry about so much.
>> Lee: That's a good point.
We definitely deal with a lot of, yeah, I
mean, I guess being overwhelmed and just kind
of sorting it out.
>> Kristin: Do what you can, do your best
and you know, have a drink.
[ laughs ]
>> Lee: That was a good one.
>> Kristin: Of Coke of course.
>> Lee: Um, so TV, Broadway, Music, almost
everything under the sun.
I was a stage manager in theatre, so they
have triple threat, obviously.
I was trying to come up with a term for someone
who does more than three things.
[Kristin laughs ] You know like you were in-
>> Kristi: Type A
[ laughs ]
>> Lee: Yeah, exactly.
So I guess we have some popular questions
from people here and also people in VC in
other offices watching.
Um and it's a Google moderated page.
They vote for the most important ones, so
we can start with one of those [audience laughs]
and take some live questions here.
We have some CDs that we are going to give
away to people that answer some of the questions
and then kind of go from here.
>> Kristin: Ah, that's great, I’m very happy.
>> Lee: I'm gonna get the live; I'm gonna
get the live.
I am trying to be very high tech, I've got
a tablet.
>> Kristin: What is that?
>> Lee: It's a tablet.
>> Kristin: Y'all probably invented it.
>>Lee: Yeah, wish I had the patent on it.
That would be great.
[ laughs ]
>> Kristin: You're right
[ laughter ]
>> Lee: One of the top questions was um, I
am sure you get this a lot; I adored Pushing
Daisies and was the saddest when it was canceled.
Are there any plans to work on a sequel project,
movie, TV special etc.?
If there are would you appear as Olive again?
>> Kristin: I would have to be dumb not to.
I mean, Brian Fuller, I always say doesn't
your head hurt from the information that is
in your head.
Much like I would say to any of you all but
I mean [ laughter ] he is so smart.
He created this world.
I knew when I read the pilot that it was going
to be something special.
Um, I knew where Olive could go and there's
talk of doing a movie.
So maybe if we all write in how much we want
him to do that.
[ laughter ] I know he is writing and has
been doing a comic for a Marvel Comics.
I like the way I look in the cartoon version
[ laughter ] I certainly sound like a cartoon
so it is like perfect.
I would love to play Olive Snook.
That's like one of my biggest, not regrets,
but like the itch that I can't scratch is
the ending to that show.
The closure and obviously I know what makes
a hit because I thought it was the most genius
thing I have ever seen.
And not just because I was in it.
I just loved it.
>> Lee: It was great,
>> Kristin: And the cast.
Lee Pace, Anna Friel, Swoosie , Ellen, Chi
– so good, so good.
>> Lee: I was catching up on a couple of episodes
from the second half of the second season
and I forgot how much I enjoyed it.
>> Kristin: Did you see the pig that I worked
with, Pigbee?
Or Digbee the dog.
>> Lee: Digbee yes.
>> Kristin: I had to work with all animals
and children.
That is so not fair.
[ laughter ]
>> Lee: Oh.
I almost brought my dog today.
>> Kristin: Oh I wish you would have, but
I love dogs.
What kind do you have?
[ laughter ]
>> Lee: Because we are not interviewing me..
>> Kristin: Who cares, who cares?
[audience laughs]
>> Lee: She is a Welsh Corgi.
>> Kristin: Isn't that what the Queen has?
[audience laughs]
>> Lee: Probably.
>> Kristin: They are so cute.
>> Lee: Do you sing for the Queen?
>> Kristin: Yes I did
>> Lee: OK, cuz I was watching The View yesterday,
[ laughter ] I actually watched it this morning
[applause and laughter]
>> Kristin: Say it loud and say it proud!
>> Lee: I say like, Whoopi Goldberg is good
at this and I'm not because I have always
been behind the scenes.
So I am going to go steal her questions.
And that was one of the questions I was going
to steal.
>> Kristin: You are so cute, it doesn’t
matter.
>> Lee: Ahh, this is rough, this is hard.
I am going to go back to the Dory questions.
>> Kristin: Where are you from?
>> Lee: I am originally from North Carolina.
>> Kristin: Oh you are, the basketball.
>> Lee: No, ahh.
Well it was basketball but I never played
any sports.
>> Kristin: Did they have a professional football
team?
>> Lee: They do now, I think it is like the
Panthers in Charlotte.
>> Kristin: Never heard of them.
>> Lee: Yeah, they weren't around when I was
growing up.
[ laughs ]
[ laughter ] I am going to do back to the
Dory cause that is easy.
>> Kristin: You're so cute.
Are you single?
[ laughter and applause]
>> Lee: Ahh.. you are not making this any
easier.
>> Kristin: I'm sorry! [ laughs ]
>> Lee: Alright, this is a good one.
>> Kristin: [ sings ] I can dream, can't I?
It's the end of my day, I am letting it loose
for you guys.
[ laughs ] Lee, Lee, Lee
>> Lee: Now your costar on Pushing Daisies
is also named Lee also.
>> Kristin: Lee Pace, who I love, who is about
seven feet tall.
I'm glad you brought him up.
I wanted to give a shout out to him and his
family.
They have just recently lost their farm in
Texas to the fires.
So, you know, I am sure he is dealing with
that.
I just love him, I think he is an amazing
actor.
More than anything though I think he is a
good person.
I just love him, I would be like, "We're running
behind.
I have been here like fourteen hours, I can't."
And he was like Buddha, Zen, calm.
He never, he was just that person, and I needed
it, so.
[ laughs ]
>> Lee: Another one of the top voted questions
was, since you do performing with Broadway
and TV shows, what are the main differences
for you as an actor and a singer?
>> Kristin: Well you know when you are doing
a Broadway show you get to hide behind or
in a character, which I loved.
[ background noise… rustling ] Um, it's
hard to just be.
I love that noise, it's amazing.
[ laughs ] [ noise continues ] I am just kidding,
you need to do your job, too, sir.
Um, I get to hide in a character and I love
that because, um, it's an opportunity to bring
an original [ noise continues ] piece of work
or a revival.
[ noise ] Playing to the back of the house
is the challenge, eight times a week.
Broadway is not for wimps; it's not for wimps.
But when you are doing TV and film you know
your performing [background noise continues
] for an audience this big or depending what
size TV.
Y'all probably have like; see?
there it is.
That's probably the size of TV you have.
[Lee chuckles]
So it is a smaller thing so you might have
to dial it in a little bit, it feels a little
bit more intimate to me.
But really to me if I am on a concert stage
in front of an orchestra, or if I'm in a dive
bar signing, or if I'm doing a film.
If I'm staying true to myself and the character,
even if the person is I'm just presenting
myself, um, in front of people.
Then I just want to always be true to that.
So it kind of, I kind of feel like I can't
miss, I might not be everyone's favorite,
but if I am true than whether it is film,
TV, theatre or concert it doesn't really matter.
To me it is all the same, it's an extension
of me.
>> Lee: It's that form of communication…that's
all right, we will real that in.
>> Kristin: See, welcome to my world.
I want you all to invent a way I can have
a microphone implanted in my body.
>> Lee: That's a great idea
[ laughter ]
>> Kristin: And you could get to patent on
that! [ laughter ]
>> Lee: I will get the engineers together
and we will start working on that.
>> Kristin: Come on guys,
>> Lee: Yeah, implants in the head, that's
a huge market opportunity to be in.
For lots, for more than just microphones.
>> Kristin: I would buy that sucker.
>> : Lee: If I could not type anymore, that
would be awesome.
>> Kristin: Do you guys, are your fingers
tired, do your arms get sore?
>> Lee: Yeah, Yeah
[ laughter ]
>> Kristin: I bet, I bet
[audience laughs]
>> Male: Are you going to come back to Broadway
anytime soon?
Are there any plans for any shows coming up?
Yeah
>> Kristin: Yeah, [ applause ] Thank you.
I really want, well I am going to revive a
show called On The Twentieth Century.
It hasn’t been done in thirty years.
The woman that created the role Lily Garland
was Madeline Kahn, who my dog is named after.
She is one of my favorite actresses and singers
that ever lived.
[ applause ] Thank you, I love her too.
She is my favorite.
Um, so I will look forward to that because
it is operatic in nature but it is a comedy.
[ burps ] That's what happens when you have
a Coke.
[ laughter ]
And there, my record sales just went down.
Anyway, that's the most balls I have ever
had in my voice right there.
Anyway, um, wow, my mom is so proud right
now.
[ laughter ] But I also am working on a show
that I will do too.
The first thing will be On The Twentieth Century
and then the second is the sort of life story
of Tammy Faye Bakker.
I don't know if any of you remember her but
she was a really well known televangelist
wife and she was on television as well as
a very unique, funny, interesting woman and
character.
So Henry Krieger who composed Dream Girls
is composing that, we did our first reading
not long ago.
It's amazing music, but I look forward to
coming back to Broadway anytime they will
have me.
>> Lee: Excellent, excellent, um, yeah.
We have a lot of questions.
I want to hear your thoughts briefly on, um,
Steel Pier as well actually cause I did the
tour after I left Broadway briefly in 2001.
>> Kristin: What?
Did you have a part?
Don't tell me who?
>> Lee: No, I was a stage manager.
No, I never performed a day in my life.
This is actually the fourth time I have ever
been in front of a camera.
>> Kristin: What?
You should always be in front of a camera.
[ laughs]
>> Lee: I'll pass, I'll pass.
>> Kristin: OK, yeah, Steel Pier.
I loved it.
>> Male audience member #1: Thanks for being
here.
Could you please tell us about your most embarrassing
moment on stage?
>> Kristin: It just happened.
[ laughs ] that burp.
Um, let's see.
There was a show I did at the Guthrie Theatre
in Minneapolis called Babes in Arms.
It was gonna come to Broadway but it ultimately
didn't get there.
I had a job of tap dancing down a big stairway
of piano keys.
Sing and dance this song, be a part of this
number called Keys to Heaven.
And I had a big time quick change right before
the number where I had to change my wig in
like fourteen seconds.
And I had just did my own wig every night
with just two pins cause then I would change
again and put my normal wig back on.
And um, I was sort of dressed like a Carmen
Miranda type character and I remember I was
doing the big [short pause].
And I felt like something might have come
off my hair or something and I was like, oh
well, [ sings ] Keys to Heaven.
And I am looking out and there is like people
going [ gasps and covers mouth making noise
] and this is what I see.
[ laughter ] and I realize my wig is on the
floor.
Bald cap, microphone, this.
just dancing away.
You know, um, I finished the number completely
bald and then put the wig back on my head
when it was over.
It was embarrassing and then three weeks later
I am doing the same show.
And like at Act II there is this thing that
enters, it's like a bomb.
This thing that comes out of the audience
and I am waiting at intermissions.
I can sometimes here the people talk before
I enter because of intermission.
And I hear, this honest to goodness, this
is like three weeks later, "and then her wig
fell off and she kept dancing."
I was like, oh, they are talking about me.
Anyway it was like a p.s. to the most horrifying
moment.
>> Male audience member #1: Thank you
>> Lee: Do you want a CD?
>> Kristin: Oh good, I hope you like it.
Thank you.
I love the Dave Matthews Band too, aren't
they amazing?
[ laughs ]
>> Female #1: Thank you for coming.
My husband actually met you, gosh, after you
did Charlie Brown you went to see the first
regional production of Charlie Brown after
you closed and you sat down with the cast
and my husband was Charlie Brown.
>> Kristin: What?
I remember it, I remember that.
>> Female #1: So I am here for him and for
me.
>> Kristin: Well you tell him hi-
>> Female #1: I will, I'll say "Bob, Kristin
said HI!"
>> Kristin: hi and that's the only production
I have ever seen of Charlie Brown.
>> Female #1: Aww, he will be thrilled.
First of all we love Glee at my house and
thank you for being in it.
A couple of years ago we took my mother-in-law
to the concert as a surprise at Radio City.
You weren't there but they were playing the
sound track and a ten year old behind me said
"Oh my God, I love this song so much!" and
it was you singing One Less Bell to Answer.
>> Kristin: Are you kidding me?
>> Female #1: And what struck me in 2009 when
that happened was a ten year old was thrilled
to hear you sign Burt Bacharach and so I wanted
to ask you.
It's amazing to me, but,
>> Kristin: It is amazing to me too.
I am serious, I'm serious.
That he would know that music..
>> Female #1: You brought that music back.
So I wondered who would you like the current
generation of tweens to hear?
Either through Glee or what music could we
bring back that they need to hear?
>> Kristin: Ah,, that's a great question.
You know I, too, love the fact that Glee has
brought, you know in one episode, in the first
episode I did, I did "Maybe This Time" from
Cabaret.
I did a Carrie Underwood song called "Last
Name".
And I did a seventies rock, Heart is the group,
I did "Alone".
And Ryan Murphy, like those three songs completely
different, he has done such a good job at
bringing all different kinds of music to this
show.
Which is why it's struck such a cord and why
it makes me happy that a nine year old kid
go "I love this song!"
Um, I would love to see, you know, a resurgence
of the thirties.
I mean, in the thirties and forties music,
that was actually my first record I ever made
was that kind of music.
Gershwin, Rodgers and Hart, um, you know we
have wonderful composer today but there is
a sense of innocence, that time that we can
revisit.
And to make it current again would be amazing.
But when I think of even you know Cole Porter,
oh gosh, there is too many to mention.
That is probably my favorite era.
I would love to see that come back more.
>> Lee: That's a good question.
So you also won a Tony for "Good Man Charlie
Brown".
So I have got to put that in there.
[ laughs ]
>> Kristin: Thank you
>> Lee: And um, I guess it is kind of a follow
up question for, on the Glee side of things.
Were you ever in show choir?
How did you get your start?
Was--
>> Kristin: Well my start was in Church.
I grew up in Broken Arrow, Oklahoma and our
only outlet of performance was either that
or cheerleading.
Which I did cause I was like, I can perform,
but I faked the yelling.
I was a flyer, which is why I smashed my cooter
[ laughs ] I know people have heard this.
I broke my coccyx cause I was on the top and
somebody got tired and let me down.
I was in the splits and I was like [ crushing
noise ] with my coccyx, I call it the cooter
smash.
But anyway, yeah, the funny thing with me
and cheerleading was I faked yelling cause
I didn't want to hurt my voice.
I would be like [ pause ] I did it.
This one girl, who will remain nameless, was
like "You're faking it!" and I was like "I
know I am!"
But we didn't have show choir but what we
did have, which has made me even as nerdy
as you can get, we had Madrigals.
[ laughs ] Yes, and of course I was the leader
of the madrigals.
I loved madrigals cause you had to audition
and of course it was like me, auditioning,
no body else.
But that holds a special place in my heart.
I was a big fan of the King Singers, this
madrigal group and, um, yeah, so I was in
madrigals, I did the choirs concerts, I did
the drama club, and I was a silent cheerleader
[ laughs ] and I sang at rodeos.
I sang at anything I could because that was
the only outlet I had.
>> Lee: Well you certainly had a great career
ever since then.
And I also heard that ABC picked up a show
called "Good Christian Belles" is coming out
as well.
>> Kristin: Yeah, Good Christian Belles
>> Lee: I caught a little tidbit online and
I know now necessarily you are not supposed
to believe everything you read, or see online,
although someone did mention to me that you
said you gotta sing from your cooter.
Now that we are on the subject, is that true
and how does that work?
I'm asking too many questions, umm.
>> Kristin: I can tell you later, Lee!
[ laughter ]
>> Lee: Um so I heard, um, yeah, I am going
to a completely different subject.
So the ABC show had a different name of the
pilot, is that true?
>> Kristin: Yeah, Good Christian rhymes with
witches.
>> Lee: Um, OHH
>> Kristin: But it was based on a book that
Kim Gatlin wrote out of Dallas, a wonderful
writer, very funny.
It was basically her experience about getting
divorced and moving back from a big city to
Dallas and what she went through with the
girls that she grew up with and how they accepted
her.
It is really less about religion and more
about relationships, which is very fun.
It's funny, I would never do anything that
made fun of anyone's religion.
So um, there is a difference in making fun
of and having fun with and I think that's
what he did so well.
Bobby Harling, who wrote Steele Magnolias
and certainly knows how to write women, wrote
it.
We have Annie Potts, Jennifer Aspen, Marisol
Nichols, Leslie Bibb and Miriam Shor, some
of you may know from Hedwig here in New York.
I must say, I am really proud of it.
We are in the middle of shooting right now
so I've taken just one week off to talk about
my record and I'll go on tour when we wrap.
But we are doing ten episodes then we will
get our air date soon.
>>Lee: I don't see how you do it all, first
of all.
>> Kristin: I have no life.
>> Lee: I had a question; "What do you do
with your free time?"
I was like, scratch that off the list.
>> Kristin: Here is what I do; Hillbilly Handfishing,
Dance Moms, Real Housewives of New Jersey,
I mean it's mindless because sometimes I just
need to just turn off my brain.
You guys understand this, you just need to
turn off your brain sometimes, so what better
way than reality TV.
[laughter]
>> Lee: Those really seem to do the trick.
>> Kristin: [ laughs ] No kidding.
>> Lee: Well I guess we can go to another
live question, and give another CD here.
>> Male #2: Ah, So clearly so much for your
art has to do with music and singing, right,
with all of your Broadway and your record
and everything.
And then you did this very sort of straight
role, comedic, but on a drama on the West
Wing, right, so what was it like doing that?
What made you decide you wanted to do that?
>>Kristin: Um, Thank you for asking that question.
I loved the West Wing but I had been offered
this show and then I had been offered Wicked
so I had to decide which one I was going to
do and I took Wicked.
[ applause and cheers ]
>>Lee: Thank-you
[laughter]
>>Kristin: And I think it might have been
the right decision.
And then Aaron Sorkin, the creator of West
Wing, had left the show and John Wells took
over, another amazing show runner and writer,
creator in his own right.
He had asked me to come on as Annabeth Schott,
and Annabeth was the Deputy Press Secretary
getting into everybody.
First in line Richard Schiff's character 'Toby'
to become, first in line to become Press Secretary
when Allison Janney's character stepped into
a new part.
And I was really nervous because I am not
really political, like I should never talk
politics because I would live with my foot
would just be hanging out of my mouth.
But I learned a lot.
I learned a lot about different countries
and how they did things.
Martin Sheen is, gosh, he taught me a lot.
Everybody on that show was so knowledgeable
in this particular area and I can see why
because you kind of have to get there because
you are talking about it so much.
I would get these monologues about Uzbekistan,
this long, and I would be like "Is that by
Prada, Prada, is that a leather?"
[laughter]
Anyway but I learned.
My point is I learned so much and I grew a
lot as an artist.
Precisely why I took the part, is what you
said, I wanted to do something in a world
that people might not put me in.
And it worked out, I was supposed to do three
episodes and I did two seasons.
So, I loved it, I loved it.
Thank you.
>> Lee: Here's your CD.
Also there is two..
>> Kristin: Nice to meet you.
>> Lee: two questions.
We are going to save the last CD for you,
young lady, but one second and we will come
back to you.
Theirs is two questions in the Dory are kind
of related.
One of them is; Was there ever a point in
your career where you almost, or you felt
like you almost gave up, or you were just
having a tough time?
And the other related question is; What advice
would you give to aspiring actors?
>> Kristin: Well it is related.
>> Lee: Or artist.
>> Kristin: I am going to answer the second
half first.
I've heard, I have said this many times, people
have heard me answer this question before
and I never have to think about it because
I know what the answer is.
This life, career, is so rewarding but if
you can see yourself doing anything else and
being happy then you should do it.
Because this, this can be hard.
There is a lot of sacrifice and a lot of challenge
and you are selling yourself.
It is very hard not to take things personally,
no matter what level you are you get constant
rejection, it doesn't matter.
I was sitting in an audition many years ago
and a very famous academy award winner was
sitting next to me and she was auditioning
for the mother part.
And I said; "Why are you here?" and I think
you have and Academy A-- I worship you!" and
she goes "I'm here to audition."
Just because you get an award doesn't mean
it's over.
In a way it's more risk involved, you know,
microscope is really there.
So that being said, if you can't see yourself
doing anything else and being happy then you
should go for it.
Because it is the greatest gift to be able
to do what you love and I know because I get
to do what I love.
And, um, not everybody can say that and I
am very lucky.
And it has been hard, there have been times
where I have been [pause] low, I get depressed,
there is this perception about me that I am
happy all the time.
I wake up "I'm going to get ready now!
I'm going to put on my shoes!"
[laughter]
Umm you know, they say that comedians are
actually very tortured people.
[giggles] That comedy comes through drama,
it's just sped up.
Um, and I can understand that, but am I basically
a happy person, Yes.
I have a lot to be thankful for.
I have a healthy family.
I have an awesome pet that I love so much.
I have great friends, my mom and dad love
m;, they gave me the gift of self esteem.
And I love it; I love it, but it is hard,
it's hard.
>> Lee: sounds like good words to live by
>> Kristin: It is right?
>> Lee: Someone gave me similar advice, don't
write a song unless you have to.
>> Kristin: That's great!
>> Lee: You have to have that passion behind
it and it's
>> Kristin: Yeah, you do!
If you have something to say, say it!
>> Lee: Do you want to go for another live
question?
>> Female #2: Do you have any advice for people
looking to get into theatre?
>> Kristin: Well I definitely say, when I
was nineteen before I went to OCU.
I went to Oklahoma City University for music.
My father, I had auditioned for Opryland for
the summer.
I love Opryland, they have put out a mall,
which I love malls, but I am really mad at
that mall because it took the best music place
in the world to me.
Um, I auditioned, got into a show called 'Way
Out West' and then I had to go back to school.
And my dad said "You are going to go back
to school."
And I was like "NO, I was going to, I'm actually
going to stay in Nashville, I'm going to work
in Opryland for the rest of my life."
And he says "No, you're going to go."
And I said "That's sweet of you, but thank
you [ laughs ] I am going to go ahead and
stay here."
And he's like "I'm coming to get you now."
And took me back.
And thought I went kicking and screaming.
I am so thankful that I had my education,
that I had a higher education.
It gave me an opportunity to hone my craft,
which I still work on.
It gave me an opportunity to experience a
little bit of life on my own without the roof,
of being under the roof of my parents.
It gave me opportunities to screw up and see
what that feels like by myself.
It gave me opportunities to win and see what
that felt like, so I grew up a lot.
Um, so I would say New York, and LA and Nashville
and all these other awesome places to work
and perform are always going to be there.
You have your whole life, so as much training,
cause there are so many talented people out
there.
It just gives you an edge up if you have the
skill to back the craft.
So I would say, educate, learn, take class,
whatever that means for you.
That's the best advice I can give.
And enjoy it, have fun!
You're welcome.
I hope you like my record.
[ laughs ]
>> Lee: So you are an avid Twitter user.
>> Kristin: I love Twitter.
>> Lee: Yeah, I was going to--
>> Kristin: I love it
>> Lee: I was going to ask what is your favorite
way to connect with your fans but I think
the answer to that is Twitter.
I think you've, I've got 7000 Tweets, 400,000
followers along those lines or something like
that.
>> Kristin: It's so crazy when I think about
it.
I like to be able to say, first I thought,
I don't understand the concept of Twitter.
Ashton; "Are you kidding me.
I am having a hamburger right now, now I'm
going to the mall."
That’s so dumb.
[laughter] Now I am like "This man at the
airport is picking his toenails."
I mean, I think it is so, I love Twitter.
I love hearing as much as the followers of
me like to hear from me I like to hear from
them.
Like, the other day, this women was like "I
bite my tongue and who knew that the next
day a chunk would be missing and it hurt so
bad!"
I was like "I am so sorry, that has to suck!"
I like to hear [ laughs ] I like to hear just
regular, cause I am pretty much down to earth.
It's kind of what you see is what you get.
So, um, anyway, that's why I love it, I love
it!
>> Lee: Have you ever considered using Google
plus?
[ laughter ]
It's kind of like Twitter.
>> Kristin: Well when you ask me like that.
[ laughter ]
>> Lee: Yeah, I think there is software where
you can send Tweets and Facebook stuff and
Google plus, we'll definitely hook you up
there.
>> Kristen: You should hook me up.
Well all right.
>> Lee: It's pretty similar but you can, you
don't have to constrain yourself to however
many characters it is.
You can--
>> Kristen: This has been my problem.
[laughter]
>> Lee: Um, solved, solved, right here.
I know we could, we could,
>> Female #3: [comments off mic]
>> Lee: We could, we could
>>Kristin: [singsongy] we could!
>> Female #3: No I didn't mean here…
>> Lee: Oh yeah, woooshsh! [ sighing ]
>> Kristin: [ laughter ] Later, later.
In private!
No I am just kidding, just kidding, you know
I am just giving you crap.
>> Lee: Um, how much time do we have?
Do we have much time left?
Is anyone going to cut me off, no, keep going?
Alright, alright, I'm out of CDs, I know you
wanted one beforehand.
I will give you mine.
>> Kristin: No, I have one in my purse.
>> Female #4: Then I want the one from your
purse!
It's extra special.
>> Kristin: Done!
[ laughter ]
Done !
>> Female #4: I loved when you sang "For Good"
for Oprah for her last show as her Morehead
graduates surrounded her.
>> Kristen: Thank you
>> Female #4: And I was wondering what did
you envision a moment like that for yourself,
what would that moment be?
Who has changed you for the better?
>> Kristin: Oh my God, I love this question.
Nobody has ever asked me that.
>> Female #4: Are you serious?
I actually though; "She's probably been asked
this over and over again."
>> Kristin: I would never be, could never
be famous enough or good enough to be Oprah,
but that moment, um.
Oh, man, I love this question, I think obviously
we all look for ways to give back and I do
have a charity [ laughs ] Cause I know people
are going "of course" But I do, I love animals
and I have a charity called Maddie's Corner.
My dog Madeline Kahn, she started the charity.
She whispered through her paw one night; "start
this charity under my name."
But it basically helps animals get placed
into the right home for them.
Because a lot of times we hear about dog that
get, you know, into a very kid friendly and
they are not used to kids.
So it helps facilitate that and sometimes
people who need animals, so it's animals helping
people helping animals is the theme.
So, in my perfect world, and we are a long
way from this, is that every displaced dog
or cat or bird or snake or whatever, would
be in the right home.
Like, I could image if someone was singing
"For Good" and I was an old lady and like
all these dogs and cats and you know, with
their owners, I would just die.
I just love animals, I just love them.
And I love children too, those who can't speak
for themselves.
Just, it kills me, I cannot, if I see a St.
Jude commercial, I am like [ crying ] here
is $70,000.
I won't be able to eat but I don't care.
[ laughter ] I just can't if someone's been
abused or hurt or can't help themselves, I
just can't, I know everybody is the same,
it's not like I am special in this belief,
but that would be my moment.
Thank you for asking me that, that was an
incredible moment for her to see what she
has done.
>> Female #5: [Inaudible]
>> Kristin: She did the ugly cry, she did.
I was just talking to, I did the Gail King
radio show today and she was saying that that
was a very special moment because it forced
Oprah.
Who's not always, we may always see her giving
but receiving is hard for her.
So she had to receive that and so I was so
glad she was able to let loose and see what
she had done, put all these men through college.
I mean, "what?"
Talk about making your mark on this world.
She is great.
Thank you.
>> Lee: We have um, so I guess, kind of coming
back to Nashville and when you were in, you
have a film and you are in New York, LA and
so I guess that you kind of came back to Nashville.
Was it something that were kind of doing all
along?
I spent a little time in Murfreesboro , I
went to school in Murfreesboro, actually.
>> Kristin: Oh you did, where?
>> Lee: Middle Tennessee State ??
>> Kristin: MSTU right?
>> Lee: Yeah, and I was like "What am I doing
here?" after a while.
But after you mentioning Nashville.
>> Kristin: But they have such good food.
>> Lee: There is good food there, there is
good food.
>> Kristin: I know.
>> Lee: So how was that for you?
Was it a great experience?
Do you feel like it was kind of referring
to something familiar?
>> Kristin: I mean, I grew up in a southern
state and I grew up singing and hearing that
kinds of music.
You know a lot of people on Broadway grew
up listening to cast albums and going to Broadway
shoes, or tours and we didn't have that in
Broken Arrow.
We had cast albums and I did like Les Mis
and the main ones.
But I had never heard of, like, certain shows
so I was into country music and gospel music.
That was my whole thing so when I went to
do Opryland I feel in love with Nashville
and I always said 'One day I would be back."
And I'm twenty years later, um, back in Nashville
recording this record.
Someone asked me the other day "Why country,
why now?"
[ laughs ]
I understood the question cause that is not
what I am known for, but since I was this
big, and I am now only this big [laughs ] since
this big I wanted to make an album like this.
So I am thrilled to put this country-pop feel
into the world and let people know how I grew
up singing and I co-wrote a couple of the
songs so I am putting myself out there as
a songwriter, too.
Which is very scary, um and it's scary to
release an album like this cause you don't
know if it will be accepted, you know.
But I know that the product, I am so proud
of the things I got to say, which is you get
to do that when you get to make a record.
It's about what you have to say, so, um, Bob
Ezrin who did Pink Floyd's 'The Wall' and
Alice Cooper and you name it, he was my producer.
I had great songwriters, the best musicians
in Nashville and I just loved my time there.
My jeans were so tight when I left cause I
was like "meat and three".
They have this thing there like in Oklahoma
too like, ribs or brisket and you get three
sides.
You can pick macaroni and cheese,
>>Lee: okra
>>Kristin: fried okra, I mean it was a smörgåsbord
; it was a festival of eating every day.
I loved it so much, um, yeah, I loved Nashville.
[ laughs ]
>> Lee: The food always comes back to Google,
pretty good food here at lunch.
And so most people are like "what's the best
things about Google?"
>> Kristin: It's the food.
Your building is like unbelievable.
How many people work here?
>> Lee: Close to 2,000 I think; 3,000?
>>Kristin: Are you joking?
>>Lee: No way!
Really?
So it used to be-- [laughs]
>> Kristin: I hope you guys like each other.
[ laughter ]
>> Lee: There is also enough room, now, so
we don't have to see one another.
>> Kristin: You can tell it is a beautiful
space.
>> Lee: It's great.
Well, thank-you so much for coming.
I think we are out of time.
Let everyone please give it up for Kristin
Chenoweth.
[ applause ]
>> Kristin: Thank-you for having me.
Thank-you, guys!